to give you a first look at Star Wars
Outlook and
and gameplay so thank you
Julian
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God he said Outlook
calm down do you want to see gameplay or
not
all right
let's get over the speech and let's get
to the gameplay
oh
takes place in a time of great civil
unrest okay
for some why Productions are hard this
is a time of turmoil it's hot
for outlaws
this is a time of opportunity this
game's kind of a tough sell for me uh
that's what Star Wars these days I
really like the Jedi series companion
NYX fight for survival every single day
relying on their skills and
resourcefulness to get by
as they struggle to make ends meet
Kay and Nix you're right they're not new
to this they should they should know
better and then all the presentations
have been good bring back Yusuf
okay unexpectedly becomes one of the
Galaxy's Most Wanted
so to free herself
from the Bounty that follows her
Kay will need to pull off one of the
greatest heists the outer rim has ever
did he say let's skip the speech and
then start a speech it's a really good
point the underworld I'm okay with the
speeches
ruthless villains Kay and Nix will
manage their reputation by taking on
risky contracts and navigating complex
relationships
no I think this presentation is just
rough because the summit game Fest
wasn't pre-recorded
and that didn't feel this way I think
it's the promptest I think it's the
telephone Journey will take them across
they are hard to read from naturally if
you've never done it varied open World
locations and the wild like a shoes
one of these locations hey I like the
pants I respect this man's style I think
he looks nice teaches Windswept Savannah
and amberine canyons
carved into tashara's striking landscape
very pretty the city of miragana yes you
have to have much less talking which I
think is a thing of scum and villain
we've started to notice
Knicks will encounter several criminal
syndicates
that learned that everything
um is measured we don't like the talking
that's what's changed we like the pace
which I think actually PlayStation set
up hard credits
this presents an abundance of
opportunities and dangers
for a young ambitious scoundrel-like k
Nintendo to do you want to be right
actually it's probably the Nintendo
directs that started it
along with Ubisoft ANSI Barcelona
Bucharest Chengdu Milan Montpellier
Paris Shanghai Toronto
that's cool and our amazing
team at lucasfilm games it's our
privilege
to present to you this first ever look
Star Wars Outlaws gameplay
if you're willing to take the risk just
come on the Galaxy is full of
opportunity thank you
okay thank you
powered by Ubisoft Snowdrop I like that
you should dial as host she's funny
[Music]
it's very cute it is very cute they know
what they're doing
oh
that fighter stripped for parts by
tomorrow
all right next let's go get paid
that worked
you like that animation
we cannot trust those officers they take
our credits now but what stops them from
stabbing Us in the back
hit that button
oh my God he's really cute
it's really cute
nice one I wonder if this is gonna be
more like a watchdogs
hang on tight little buddy
yeah I mean this environment's really
pretty
um but it again Hard Sell to make me
want to play this game
when I'm so happy with the Survivor
series
hey uh I was just leaving
okay okay we'll figure this out
[Music]
Shield
that melee looks really cool
foreign
BioShock
this is getting bad
let's try this out it's so cute
beautiful environment
oh is this game also open world
right
[Music]
these guys don't very pretty like this
after Mirage is nuts man
hang on
okay
it's like Dead Eye
bullet time
that's again
95 I got the package where are you
waiting for you and jaunt us hope
I said I got it what else matters I like
her
um well they'll probably forgive me
comforting
so even if this is the same open World
style we made it next
as you have Far Cry Assassin's Creed it
certainly does look different
which Avatar
kind of did not
oh that's cool
the wind making these little rocks roll
across the world
very pretty
hey Andy
your late cake Doc is waiting what are
you worried no
okay
no but you're Troy what
be careful
danka's a broker not a friend she can't
be trusted
who can out here
see you back at the ship
wouldn't it be cool if it had crossed
over with
Cal and the Survivor
okay
this
back already
I told you she's fresh but she's good
who's this
who's a friend
join us
job was more complicated than you said
Danka
you lived
hey these aren't toys
he's the beauty one and I love him
wait
we haven't met
I don't really know many of you
stealing illegal Contraband running with
syndicates I could say you're a threat
to the Empire
but I won't have to if you're smart
bribe do not bribe thanks I'm smart
enough to get myself out of trouble you
pay the tax just like everyone else whoa
kid let's just relax
these are very pretty like some of the
prettiest of ubisoft's cutscenes maybe
ever Maybe
obviously very much ahead of time not to
say it'll look like that on release but
uh
it doesn't really look like a unique
that's cool
is that Imperial announcement wouldn't
be about you would it uh could be it's
not like a GTA
style one two thing or is it only
scripted I wonder if you can get it
unscripted
definitely not calcas
we need to leave yeah no kidding
this game does look good
[Music]
you get to fly it as well
damn
okay
wow
[Music]
but does it have a thousand planets if
not I don't want it
dude
cool
the sensors now whoa firefighters on us
got one
I feel inclined that's really impressive
the Empire quickly thanks I'm working on
it
yes but they're all Tatooine every
planet you can visit all thousand of
them are all sand planets
[Music]
Andy get us out of here
let's jump
[Music]
yeah the uis looks fantastic in my
opinion also cool that the Empire is
still chasing them look at like it's
it's just maybe now going away when they
jumped
we made it
does have some of the similar Concepts
they're working on to be on good evil
actually when I saw that however many
years ago they did have this like Anna
planet and you zoom out and you zoom out
and you zoom out focus so maybe it's
literally some of the same Tech
[Music]
that's your new toy
so where do we go next
anywhere we want
[Music]
impressed man
um
still not totally sure if I'm gonna want
to play this
would like more information
uh I don't feel like I need to
long-ass Star Wars games in a year
[Music]
but I'm very impressed by this
and it is me and Magic
[Music]
it's a lot more unique than some of the
other games in the presentation
I would say yeah Ubisoft for me today
has been Outlaws is looks awesome Prince
of pleasure looks awesome
okay it's next year so
maybe I'll want to play it when we've
had a bunch of space from uh
from Jedi survival
that's not so bad
[Music]
that did look really good